what do you think the chances are that
you would have to go to the hospital if
you got covert
and Democrats thought that was way
higher than Republicans 41 of democrat
and the answer is between one and five
percent okay 41 percent of Democrats
thought it was over 50 percent
another 28 thought it was 20 to 49 so 70
percent of Democrats thought it was way
way way higher than it really was
liberal media has to take a little
responsibility for that for scaring the
out of people audience there you
could feel how quiet they are and how
afraid of laughing they are because he's
calling out their machine it is the
Democrat machine that made Democrats go
covid crazy it is the Democrat and media
machine right it is the cable news
networks it's big Tech all that that
monstrous machine we're always talking
about that has caused a certain set of
people that used to be sane moderates to
all go bananas